[Music]
get it all demamp in microphone
well another week now the Friday was
nothing through awesome no it was made
by Jerry see he made the intro for the
old one you know that lunch my attack
all right so the first news is that I'm
gonna start selling
Peter Piper holsters it's just gonna be
like a limited edition and it's only
available for this weekend so um yeah if
you want one get one now I will also
sign them and you can ask for any
message if it's a gift or anything like
that I will be happy to write whatever
you want unless it's something you know
dirty so I don't know it's pretty cool I
got asked blue skies to draw one special
unique design for me so if you want that
unique limited-edition could the pie
poster then be sure to order one right
now it's it's 50 x 70 in size which is
pretty much I also wanted to share a
real yep I get so many awesome fan out
from my Bros and it is I honestly when I
watch the fan art and like the things
you create for me the videos or the
songs or whatever that's really when I
feel like now that's because I don't
like I love it of course it's just that
I really feel like why do people do it I
feel guilty because I don't know they're
so awesome I like why do I do to deserve
it
it's a it's a weird feeling but I'm
really happy about every single fan art
that I get and everything you do you
bros do for me so I wanted to share some
of the awesome amazing fun I got one
really epic from Happy Wheels that I
want to share it right here and we got
some other ones all I've shown it's nice
little slideshow here mm-hmm so thank
you both for all the fan art I do watch
most of them I'm sorry I can't leave a
comment on all of them it but I do i
I've made them maybe I had a tiny
conversation with Thomas
his frictional games had I think his
head of frictional games and it's
basically it was familiar with my video
pretty she's awesome but he told me all
I don't know if I'm allowed to say this
I think I'm allowed saying but he
they're basically planning after amnesia
another big project which is also gonna
be horror or any oriented and he said it
will be a really cool for let's players
and he's interesting to see what it's
gonna be like so yeah I'm pretty pounded
by that you I'm glad we have many years
of Horrors in front of us I'm being
recognized a lot more lately by Bros on
the street it's like every time I go
outside you bros seem to find me
somewhere it's really awesome so if you
see me somewhere don't be afraid to say
holla
I I don't mind at all this thing is
funny it's funny how all this started
like I didn't put myself in front of the
camera because I wanted people to
recognize me only because you bros
suggested that you know i that you want
to see my facial reactions when I play
scary game stuff that's pretty cool I
got some other news that I can't tell
yet
god dammit I hate when I can't tell you
I want to tell you now I'm like a little
schoolgirl like also I forgot to say
about the poster a lot of you bros have
been asking for the t-shirts and because
you live in Israel or Mexico or whatever
and they might teach it website on chip
everywhere but I can basically ship
anywhere so I'm gonna do it all by hand
so I don't know this is your chance this
is your moment to get the PewDiePie
sting illegally I don't even know
anymore anyway that's pretty much all
for this Friday food Friday or preparing
a path if you have a suggestion on that
without it but that one suggestion if
there you want me to do some
real life stuff I know a lot of people
suggest a cinnamon challenge maybe I
could do something like that
leave a comment down below god I hate
that sentence overuse then right single
aim a jiggers Nitschke on the smoothie
Schneider he on her down to Mary
that's better that's more unique I like
that now checking my as always I go
through all most of the comments and I
really appreciate all the nice words you
both leave me I don't know why I keep
going like that but that's pretty much
of these we try to put it back as always
if you're not familiar fries goodbyes we
always ended with brofist all my videos
with really weird today I know it didn't
do it every single time so I know once
he joining the first this is like I'm
taking your brofist virginity right now
if you haven't done it before if you do
it once you gotta do it every freaking
time so here we go
you ready you ready for your virginity
to be taken seriously though don't think
you're too cool I'm sick of it we're no
one's too cool in Friday's video back
except you know Martin but anyway here
we go alright you ready 1 2 3
bro
[Music]